less than 48 hours and barely a quarter
of a mile away from where lilia
valuetuta was killed in the street
lincolnshire police made a significant
arrest
i can confirm that we have arrested a 22
year old man on suspicion of murder
he is now in police custody
officers detained the man
in boston central park area around 2 45
pm today
the arrest follows a combination of
intelligence and information supplied by
several members of the public
earlier in the day police released cctv
images taken by these cameras close to
the murder scene hoping that the public
may be able to provide vital information
all of the images released by police
were taken within 30 meters of each
other two of them with a man walking in
this direction down wormgate in front of
the cafe there and then that raised bed
and trellis a third with a man facing
the other way was taken in front of a
hair and beauty salon here and then the
final image was on the corner of
fountain lane and wormgate just 30
meters away from the murder scene
close to the scene a collection of
flowers and tributes to the little girl
who love to dance grows by the hour
among those paying their respects one of
her classmates marco i'm very sad about
lilia because she was my friend
i'm a colleague in class and
she was always really enthusiastic
and
she was always happy the reason i'm
coming
we
here
because
life to have a last thing before you
know
and
it's hard to find right words about
this
despite an increased police presence in
the town other parents share similar
fears that the streets are not safe for
their children
i am never going without them anymore
it's not safe the boston is not safe
anymore
it's just horrible i think everywhere is
getting bad now isn't it you know we're
hearing the teenagers being stabbed but
nine year old
despite the latest arrest lincolnshire
police say the investigation into the
murder that has devastated a community
is still very much active and will
continue
fraser moored sky news boston